مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
هذه التغطيه الخاصه والنشره الخاصه
بمناسبه العيد العشرين للعربيه اهلا بك
عادل اهلا بك وكل عام ونحن بخير وكل عام
والعربيه في تقدم وازدهار شكرا لوفائكم
الدائم عقدين من الزمن ونزلتم معنا لكي
تعرفوا اكثر نبدا بالعناوين
بايؤكد لقاده شرق اوروبا انه لا يهدف
لاطاحه واوكرانيا ترى نفسها جزءا من
الناتو بحكم الامر الواقع
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يطالب واشنطن
بضروره التعامل الدولي لمنع ايران من
امتلاك السلاح النوويه
من خط المواجهه في سوريا العربيه ترصد
مصادر تمويل داعش في السجون والمخيمات
من الواقع الحقيقي الى الافتراضيه العربيه
في عيدها العشرين تتخطى المكان والزمان
لتعرف اكثر بتقنيه افضل
ذكرت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خلال زيارته لبولندا في فبراير
الماضي ابلغ دول بخارسه التسع نواشط لا
تسعى لتغيير القياده في روسيا وذكرت
الصحيفه نقلا عن مصادر ان بايدن قال ان
الهدف من الوضع في اوكرانيا ليس تغيير
السلطه في روسيا وتضيف الصحيفه ان بايدن
بعد زياره كياف وفي اجتماع مغلق بوارسو
اضطره الى ارسال تذكير الى دول بوخرس
التسع الهدف من الوضع في اوكرانيا لم يكن
انهاء نظام بوتين
من واشنطن تنضم الينا نادي البلبيسي
مراسلتها العربيه ناديه كل عام وانت بخير
وما زلنا في العربيه هذه المره دعيني
اسالك عن خلفيات تذكير بايدن لدول بوخارست
كل عام وانت بالف خير عادل وليال طبعا
والف نجاح للعربيه تالق الى تالق طبعا لا
يوجد هناك رد فعل رسمي حتى الان من البيت
الابيض على هذه الاخبار التي يبدو بانها
سربت الى موقع لكن هذا هو تغيير في موقف
الرئيس بايدن يعني في بدايه الحرب على
اوكرانيا كان بايدن دوما يقول بانه لا
يمكن ان نتعامل مع هذا المجرم بين قوسين
وهو وصف استخدمه ضد رئيس بوتين وكانت هناك
حتى احتجاجات من لهذه التوصيفات لكن هناك
ربما واقعيه سياسيه تسود البيت الابيض
الان برغم كل الدعم الذي تقدمه واشنطن الى
الحكومه الاوكرانيه سواء كان دعم عسكري
غير مسبوق او سياسي او دبلوماسي هو انها
بالنهايه تريد انهاء هذه الحرب وهي تدرك
تماما بان انهائها سيتم عن طريق بقاء
الرئيس بوتين في المنصب لانه خروجه من
الحكم سيؤدي الى حاله فوضى وسيؤثر سيكون
هناك متغيرات سياسيه كبيره واشنطن لا
تريدها ان تحدث وبالتالي هي دوما تقول
بانها ستبقي على الرئيس بوتين يمكن ان
تتعامل معه وبامكاني ان ينهي الحرب غدا
بمجرد سحب قواته لكن بشكل عام كما تعرف
عادل سياسه الولايات المتحده المعلنه على
الاقل هي ليست تغيير اي نظام حتى عندما
نتحدث عن نظام الايراني دوما هي يعني نوعا
ما تلقى بنفسه عن الحديث بشكل مباشر على
انها تريد تغيير اي نظام وتقول بان هذا
يطلق للشعب لان يقوم بتغيير نظامه ناديه
يعني البعض
وخصوصا بك حيث كنت هناك كانوا يعني هناك
اعتبار ان هذه الزياره تمثل نقطه فاصله
بهذه الحرب وان دعم واشنطن هو لم يعد يعني
دعم من وراء البحار ودعم يعني يقبل بهذه
الحرب الى ما لا نهايه وبالتالي من هنا
التخوف تخوف الروسي من ان يكون الوجود
الامريكي هناك مع كل ما شاهدناه يعني
بالايام الماضيه من حديث عن انشطه
استخباراتيه على الحدود وغير كيف ايضا
يعني يقرا الوسط الامريكي هذا التخوف
الروسي
اولا هذه الحرب من وجهه نظر الرئيس بايدن
هي حرب استراتيجيه لمصلحه امريكيه بالدرجه
الاولى ولمصلحه اوروبيه بدرجه الثانيه
يعني نتحدث عن حلف شمال الاطلسي نتحدث عن
دور للولايات المتحده في احياء هذا الحزب
الذي كان يحتضر نوعا ما وبالتالي الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا هو هجوم على سياده
الدوله تريد ان تكون عضو في حلف الاطلسي
لكن ايضا هو هجوم على الديمقراطيات
الغربيه ووقف بوتين في اوكرانيا هو وقف له
من التقدم في دول اخرى قد يكون له مطامع
فيها مثل دول البلطيق اوستان استونيا
وغيرها وبالتالي الولايات المتحده ترى
بانه بالفعل ان الموقف المعلم هو ليس
تغيير النظام بوتين لكن فرض عقوبات عليه
لرضعه عن ما قام به لتغيير سياساته ليس
اكثر هي تستخدم كل هذا كربما وسيله او
كاداه لتغيير الوضع الحالي لكن بشكل عام
زياره الرئيس طبعا بايدن لاوكرانيا
المفاجئه وانت تحدثي مع العديد من
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين كما ذكرتي ليال هي
بالدرجه الاولى تاكيد لهذا الدعم الغير
مسبوق عسكري ودبلوماسي واقتصادي وانساني
وبالتالي وجوده هو يعني ربما موجود رمزي
بانه على ساحه القتال مع الرئيس الينسكي
يمكن ان يتحدى روسيا رغم انه كما تعرف
هناك تفاهمات دوما روسيه امريكيه وكان
هناك اعلان موضوع الامن بقدوم الرئيس
بايدن حتى لا يكون تماما من موضوع الامني
شكرا لك ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
على هذه الرساله من واشنطن
هكذا رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا ان جيش بلاده
يتبع معايير الناتو في القتال ويستخدم
اسلحته واكد ان وجود كيف في النيتو امر
حقيقي بحكم الامر الواقع
الابواب المفتوحه ليست كافيه بالنسبه لنا
اوكرانيا تسمع هذه الجمل منذ سنوات نريد
ونتوقع قرارات حاسمه من حلفائنا جيشنا
يقاتل باستخدام معدات الناتو وقواتنا
المسلحه تعمل بمعايير النيتو وجودنا في
النيتو امر واقع
هذا واكد ايضا عادل سفير اوكرانيا لدى
المانيا بان كياف تناقش مع حلفائها
احتياجاتها في حربها مع روسيا بطريقه
دقيقه للغايه مشيرا الى ان وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لم تطلب بعد نوعا معينا من
الطائرات من المانيا
بطريقه دقيقه للغايه وغنيه بالمحتوى حتى
هذه اللحظه لم اتلقى اي طلب من وزاره
دفاعنا لنوع معين من الطائرات المتوفره في
المانيا اعلم ان مثل هذه المناقشات تجري
مع دول اخرى لكن مثل هذه المحادثات لا
تحدث عبر تويتر ولكن خلف الابواب المغلقه
[موسيقى]
ناقش وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه التهديد الايرانيه على اسرائيل
والعالم ووافقه بيان اسرائيل فاكد وزير
الدفاع على اهميه التعاون الدوليه لمنع
ايران من حيازه السلاح النوويه
وفي الموازاه طبعا وصل المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفيع الى
طهران لاجراء مناقشات بشان برنامج ايران
النووي وذلك بعد اكتشاف جزئيات من
اليورانيوم المخصب بمستوى قريب من صنع
قنبله ذريه ومن المقرر ان يلتقي خلال
الزياره مدير منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد
ثيران ايضا ولكن في شان اخر خرج محتجون
بلوش عقب صلاه الجمعه في مظاهرات حاشده
رافعين لافتات تحمل شعار الموت للديكتاتور
وللحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
وايضا بشان الايراني عادل زعم الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس ان من وصفهم باعداء
طهران هم من سعوا لاشاعه التوتر والذار
بين الطلاب واولياء امورهم على خلفيه قضيه
تسمم الطالبات وقال رئيس الايراني انه وجه
وزير الداخليه والامن بمتابعه قضايا
التسمم في المدارس وتقديم تقرير كامل عن
الموضوع هذا وكان التقارير اكد التعرض
مئات الطالبات للتسمم في جميع انحاء
البلاد في وقت حذرت به اليونيسف من ان هذه
الحادثه الممكن ان لها تاثير على تعليم
الفتيات في ايران
هذه نشره مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ماذا
نتابع
حريق هائل بمحطه تخزين وقود في اندونيسيا
يقتل 14 شخصا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا نعود لمتابعه
هذه النشره الخاصه بالعيد العشرين للعربيه
الخارجيه السعوديه عن استنكار المملكه
الشديد للتصريحات المتطرفه التي ادلى بها
احد مسؤوليه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال
مطالبته بمحو قريات حوار الفلسطينيه هذا
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه رفض المملكه
التام لهذه التصريحات العنصريه مشدده على
مطالبتها للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاع
بمسؤولياته لردع هذه الممارسات المشينه
ووقف التصعيد وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين
هذا ودع الاتحاد الاوروبيه حكومه اسرائيل
الى تبرئه من تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه التي دعا بها الى محو بلده
حوار الفلسطينيه جنوبي نابلس بعد الاحداث
الاخيره واكد الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تصريحات
الوزير الاسرائيليه غير مقبوله ولا يمكن
التسامح معها وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي تمسكه
بمبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه لحل النزاع على
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
ايضا عادل على المستوى
الاردني في اعقاب تعرضها الى سلسله من
الهجمات الدبلوماسيه الاوروبي الذي وصل
الى الضفه الغربيه على راس وفد كبير من
سفراء ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين شدد على
تضامنه مع شعب الفلسطيني فلنتابع هذا اكبر
وفد دبلوماسي على الاطلاق على مستوى رؤساء
البعثات زار اي مكان في فلسطين هذه علامه
في حد ذاتها على التضامن والوقوف معكم
جنبا الى جنب
كانت لندن حطت على اجراء تحقيق في مختلف
فتى فلسطيني قربى قلقيليه في الضفه
الغربيه يوم الخميس وعبرت القنصليه
البريطانيه في القدس في حسابه على تويتر
عن اسفها بسبب عدم الاستقرار المستمر
والخسائر في الارواح في جميع انحاء الضفه
الغربيه كما كررت دعوتها الى ضبط النفس
عند استخدام الجيش الاسرائيلي للذخيره
الحيه
زعيمه حزب الخير المعارضه التركيه ميرال
اكشنار عن رفض حزبها ترشيح زعيم المعارضه
ورئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال اوغلو في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه واوضحت
اكشينار ان 5 زعماء من قاده احزاب الطاوله
السداسيه قرروا ترشيح اوغلو رغم كل
المؤشرات التي تؤكد تقدم رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ورئيس بلديه
انقره منصور يافاش في استطلاعات الراي
وامكانيه فوزهما بانتخابات الرئاسه مؤكده
ان حزبها لن يرضخ لضخوض الطاوله السداسيه
بترشيح كريتشارد
في المرحله الحاليه اضطر الحزب الصالح الى
الفرد واجبر على الاختيار بين الموت
والملاريا تماما كما حدث للامه التركيه
لسنوات وبالطبع لن يرضخ الحزب صالح الى
هذا كحزب الواي اي اعربنا عن راينا في
ترشيحين اولئك الذين سمعناهم كثيرا في
الشوارع والمتاجر والساحات العامه لاكثر
من ثلاث سنوات تلك التي شهدناها في كل
مكان تقريبا اظهرتها امتنا بشده المحسوبيه
واولئك الذين رايناهم في جميع الاستطلاعات
العامه فازوا بفارق كبير على السيد
اردوغان لفتره طويله هذان الاسمان هما
عمده مدينه انقره السيد منصوريه فاس وعمده
مدينه اسطنبول السيد اكرم امام اوغلو
كانت احزاب المعارضه التركيه اعلنت امس
الاتفاق على اسم مرشح لخوض انتخابات
الرئاسه ضد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان دون ان
يتم الك شف عن اسمي هذا المرشح وتجتمع سته
احزاب معارضه رئيسيه على مدار اشهر للوصول
الى توافق حول اسم لمنافسه اردوغان الا ان
هذه الجهود تعقدت مع تصريحات ميرال اكشنار
الاخيره
الى ملف اخر عادل حيث اعلنت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه عن تنفيذها مع شركاء
اخرين ثمان واربعين عمليه ضد عناصر تنظيم
داعش في العراق وسوريا الشهر الماضي
واوضحت القياده ان هذه العمليات اسفلت عن
مقتل 22 عنصرا من التنظيم واعتقال 25
اخرين ووصفت العمليات ضد داعش بالمهمه
لمنع التنظيم من استعاده قدرته في المنطقه
ومهاجمه الحلفاء والمصالح الامريكيه في
الخارج
التمويل المالي كان احد اهم الركائز التي
اعتمد عليها تنظيم داعش للبقاء وتمويل
عملياته حيث لجا الى السيطره على المناطق
النفطيه واقامه شبكه اموال سريه وحينما
انهار واصبح افراده في المخيمات وداخل
السجون لجا الى طريقه اخرى للوصول الى اول
الخيط توجهنا الى المخيمات التي تحتجز او
تحتجز فيها عائلات التنظيم شمال شرق سوريا
داخل مخيم الروج وهو مشهد غريب حاولنا
تفسيره وفهمه ايضا مكتب للصرافه وتحويل
الاموال للداعشيات علنا يخضع لرقابه قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وفي الباطن تخطيط يجري
يجري داخل مخيمات وخيام الداعشيات حملات
لجمع التبرعات وعمليات ابتزاز وتهريب تشرف
عليها خلايا التنظيم فلنتابع مشاهدينا هذا
التقرير ونعود
امام نافذه مكتب الصرافه ينتظرنا بترقب
وصول حوالات ماليه مشهد سيبدو مالوفا لو
كان خارج اسوار هذا المكان لكن هن زوجات
مقاتل داعش وهذا مكتب صرافه داخل مخيم روج
الذي ياوي عائله التنظيم وجلهم من الاجانب
تسمح قوى الامن في المخيم التابعه لاداره
الذاتيه شمال سوريا لمكاتب الصرافه بالعمل
داخل مخيمات الدواعش تحت رقبتها ايصال
مبالغ ماليه المقيمين هنا والذين يقولون
انها من اقاربهم
لمساعدتهم على تكاليف الحياه من وين
الحوارق
كم عاده ترسل لك ممكن هم هيك نعم شهريا
[موسيقى]
يمكن لي كل عائله داخل المخيم تسلم ما بين
دولار امريكي شهريا رسميا يقول القائمون
على المخيمات ان الاموال ترسل من ادلب
التي تسيطر عليها فصائل مواليه لتركيا او
من داخل تركيا نفسها
المصادر الاموال كلياتهم من اهاليون على
اليوتيوب اهاليهم موجودين بادلب اغلبيتهم
كلياتهم موجودين بادلب ومن تركيا ويلي
خارج
نطاق دوله تركيا او من اتلف كمان بعض
الاهالي منهم بيبعتوا على تركيا من تركيا
بيبعتوهم
من تركيا على ادلب ومن ادلب كمان بيجولا
لماذا تركيا
تركيا كلياتهم هلا ما بعرف يعني هي اساس
المقر هي
السماح بوصول الاموال العائله التنظيم
يبرره المسؤولون هنا باسباب انسانيه
فمساعده المنظمات الاغاثيه غير كافيه لسد
احتياجات العائلات اليوميه لكن الخطير عدم
قدره احد على تحديد او تتبع مصادر التمويل
تضمن
هلا اضمن النمو من داعش مثلا فيه 100
طريقه داعش تقدر تحوليها من مناطق الجفت
نص جبهه داعش وهيكل وجميع عمله واحده يعني
ما يعني ما في كبسه
تحت نساء التنظيف في مخيمات شمال سوريا
مره كثيره على مدار السنوات الماضيه في
جمع الاموال عبر حملات تبرعات باسماء
مشفره في منصات ماليه كما يحصلن على
مساعدات ماليه من متعاطفين مع داعش
والغطاء الابرز عائلتهن
بعض التحقيق والدراسه عن هالوضع
الاغلبيه لانه في بعض التواصلات عن طريق
الهواتف
وبشكل علني انه نبعث هالمصاري للاخوات
الموجودين اللي يقاومون ضمن المخيم حتى
يقوم بتربيه اولادهم بشكل افضل
وعن طريق الهواتف بيجون توجيهات يعني هل
اموال كيف
يتصرفوا فيها
اما الغايه فتمويل محاولات هروبهن او شراء
اسلحه او حتى شراء ولاءات النازحين
واللاجئين داخل المخيمات معلومات اوصلت
الاداره الذاتيه للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
ودول غربيه تم اتخاذ بعض التدابير بالفتره
الماضيه فقط يتطلب عمل مستمر لانه يعني
بلكي بعض البنوك تم كشف عنهم امام
بيحاولون يغيرون
بنوك اخرى او لمصادر اخرى
مصادر من داخل مخيم الهول رفضت الافصاح عن
هويتها كشفت ان خلايا داعش هددت عمال
اغاثه محليين يعملون مع منظمات دوليه اما
للحصول على اموال منهم او لاجبارهم على
مساعدتهم في تهريب اشخاص من داخل المخيم
فالتمويل والترهيب وفكر التنظيم المتشدد
ادوات يحافظ عليها استمرار بقائه وان كان
ذلك في المخيمات او السجون صار بن عيشوبه
العربيه
من شمال شرق سوريا
دعت منظمه الصحه العالميه الصين الى مزيد
من الشفافيه لمعرفه اصل فيروس كورونا كما
قالت الصحه العالميه انها لم تتراجع عن
التحقيقات المرتبطه بمعرفه اصل فيروس
كورونا
عبر المتظاهرون في جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه عن رفضهم لزياره الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون لبلادهم وكانت هذه
التظاهرات جزء من سلسله احتجاجات بدات هذا
الاسبوع قبل وصول ماكرون الى المحطه
الاخيره من جوله في وسط افريقيا التي سعى
من خلالها الى النائب بنفسه عن الماضي
الاستعماري لفرنسا
هذا وقال للجيش الاندونيسي ان 14 شخصا على
الاقل قتل واصيب العشرات في حريق هائل في
مستودع وقود تدير الدوله قبل ان يسيطر
عليه رجال الاطفاء وقال رئيس اركان الحريق
في المنشاه التي تديرها شركه الطاقه
الحكوميه في جاكرتا اسفر عن اصابه اثنين
واربعين اخرين على الاقل
فاصل نتابع بعده النشر بتغطيه خاصه لعيد
العربيه
العربيه كانت تحديث محتواها الخبري متواصل
وتطوير نشراتها لا يتوقف ليس في الشكل فقط
بل في المضمون ايضا
تغيرت هيكل هيكليتها دائما واخرى تخصصت في
ملفات بعينها وفي كل مره تستمر العربيه في
تطوير كافه خدماتها للبقاء مصدرا دائم
لعنواننا العريض ان تعرف اكثر
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
بانوراما
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
[موسيقى]
والان الى الزملاء راويه وطاهر مع 360
ماذا لديكم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم هذه العربيه 160
الخبر ومن جميع جوانب
قص صاروخي الروسي العنيف الذي طالق اليوم
ومدن اوكرانيا اخرى اليك تفضل
[موسيقى]
وانا صهيب وهذه اخبار الساعه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الاطار
[موسيقى]
معنى مشاهدينا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
بيرغانم للحديث عن تجربته الطويله داخل
هذه المؤسسه مؤسسه العربيه قبل ان انتقل
اليك يعني كان من المفترض ان يبدا عادل
معك ولكن قال لي لا استطيع ان اسال لماذا
في بدايات عملي في العربيه كنت انظر الى
بير على انه استاذنا ونجم ولا استطيع ان
اوجه له سؤالا بعد 20 عام وما زال
يعني عشرين عام في هذه المؤسسه تطورت
تغيرت ولكن الثوابت ما زالت موجوده كيف
يعني تتحدث عن هذه التجربه الطويله وما
زلت شاب
لكي تشعر
يا عادل كل عام كل عام وانتم بخير
اعزائي على القلب وكمان مناسبه عزيزي
اول شيء لازم نقول انه نحن كبرنا كبرنا
بمعنى انه تجربه 20 سنه جعلت منا اشخاص
افضل جعلت منها صحفيين افضل ربما كان الهم
في العام 2003 هو اننا كمراسلين او
كمحررين او مذيعين ان ننقل اكبر كم من
الاخبار يهم المشاهدين اعتقد انه مع الوقت
اصبحت نشرات الاخبار ذات هويه اكثر
تعطي اخبار مهمه بشكل افضل ومحدده بشكل
افضل واصبحت تعطي ايضا اطارا للاخبار مفيد
جدا
للمشاهد واعتقد اننا جميعا
نشرات الاخبار تطورنا مع هذه التجربه الى
ان وصلنا الى الصيغه التي نراها اليوم
هويه الخبر العربي كانت دائما يعني طاغيه
بكل ما قمت فيه على مدى السنوات الماضيه
من المنافس الاساسي كان لك طيله هذه
السنوات وكيف يعني لم يكن عملك محصور
بتقديم الماده الاخباريه العاديه التي
يراها المشاهد على الهواء
اعتقد ان المنافس الحقيقي للعربيه هو
الاعلام الامريكي الاعلام الامريكي بشكل
عام اعلام متطور ممتده على الاراضي
الامريكيه ممتد داخل المؤسسه الامريكيه
كان المؤسسه السياسيه او البيت الابيض او
وزاره الخارجيه او وزاره الدفاع او
الكونجرس الامريكيه اهم تحدي امام مراسل
مثلي انا او مثل الزملاء في مكتب واشنطن
هو ان نقدم ماده اعلاميه تنافس
النيويورك تايمز وتنافذ ايضا الوشوند
وباقي المؤسسات التلفزيونيه الامريكيه
اقول ذلك لسبب مهم برايي وارجو ان يكون
ذلك هو ذاته عند المشاهدين المشاهد يعتبر
ان الخبر الصادر عن مؤسسه مثل الوول ستريت
او مثل سي ان ان انه خبر ذو مصداقيه خلال
السنوات العشر الماضيه عملت بشكل واضح على
ان اقدم خبرا للمشاهد العربي ينافس هذه
الصحافه الامريكيه العريقه
المزاجيه المتلقي العربي او المشاهد
العربي اختلفت ما بين يعني منذ انطلاقه
العربيه قبل عشرين عاما كان ينظر الى
واشنطن انها صنع القرار مصدر صنع القرار
اليوم المشاهد العربي يتابع كل تفاصيل
الشان الامريكي تغير عليك شيئا انت كمراسل
على الارض
اعتقد ان ما تغير هو العالم العربي وليست
امريكا العالم العربي تطور بشكل كبير جدا
بشكل خاص المملكه العربيه السعوديه تغيرت
ايضا بشكل كبير جدا خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه وبالتالي تغطيه
العمليه السياسيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو امر مهم جدا لان الانتخابات
الرئاسيه او الانتخابات النصفيه هي دائما
مهمه بالنسبه للمشاهده العربيه ولكن تغطيه
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وباقي دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي السعوديه
في مقدمتهم مصر اسرائيل الاردن العراق
لبنان سوريا كل هذه الامور هي امور مهمه
ولكن اهم شيء ان العالم العربي تغير ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحاول ان تجد
مكانا لها
ونفوذ لها في هذه المنطقه ونحن نحاول ان
نقرب ما بين الفكره المنطبعه عن الولايات
المتحده
يعني حتى القنوات الامريكيه في اليوم
المراسلين المراسلين العرب اقصد هذا هو
شاننا هذا هو هدفنا هذا هو هدفنا
ابقى معنا لو سمحت سنعود اليك بعد قليل
الحديث عن بيار غانم وليس فقط المؤسسه
العربيه ماذا تغير ابرز اللحظات التي مررت
بها وما ابرز ما تتذكر بكل هذه المسيره
الطويله مع قناه العربيه طيب مع انجازات
العربيه في مجال الابداع البصري في
التغطيات التي وصلت اصدارها للعالميه
بجوائز عده جاءت ولاده برنامج الساعه 60
منتصف العام 2021 ليمثل علامه فارقه في
الاعلام العربي على الصعيد التقدم والتطور
في الابهار والمحتوى الصحفي مزيد للحديث
عن هذا البرنامج ستنضم الينا في الاستديو
بعد قليل مقدمه البرنامج حنين الشولي
ابقوا معنا
اربطوا الاحزمه واسترخوا هذه رحله الى
عالم اخر سنمزج فيه الافتراضي والمعزز
كلمات معقده صحيح حنين دعيني اوفر عليك
الوقت تعالوا معي
لايقاع سريع ومختلف جدا
نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق وبين العاجل
والمهم
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره الكامله الساعه
ستوت الجمعه والسبت الثامنه على شاشه
العربيه
معنا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الزميله حنين
الشولي مذيعه برنامج الساعه 60 على
العربيه حنين يعني عندما نقول الساعه 60
نقول برنامج بدا في عصر التكنولوجيا في
عصر السوشيال ميديا في عصر يعني تحول في
الخبر من جامد الى خبر يعني ديناميكي اكثر
ما الذي ادخله هذا البرنامج على الخبر
بالعالم العربي اولا اهلا بك ليال كل عام
وانتم بخير كل عام والعربيه بخير بالف خير
والزملاء بالف خير
تسلمي برنامج الساعه ستون اولا في
18/6/2021 كانت الولاده لهذا البرنامج
طبعا استمد كل هذه
التقنيات والخبرات
لخروج هذا البرنامج
ليرى النور كانت هي خبره العربيه الطويله
في الابهار والابداع الب اعتمادا على
الواقع المعزز والواقع الافتراضي طبعا
البرنامج الى جانب هذا الابهار البصري في
المحتوى المتين له اللي استطعنا من خلال
دمج الابداع البصري مع
التحرير او الجهد الصحفي انه نطلع بطريقه
جديده لطرد الخبر ولسرد القصه وهو الستوري
تالينك فبالتالي كان شكل هذا الشيء تغيير
كثير كبير في الاعلام العربي لانه صار كان
هو التجربه الاولى ولا يزال متفرد بطريقه
عرضه للخبر
في الكثير من الزوايا التي تتعلق بالابهار
البصري استخدام الواقع الممتد ايضا هي
كانت التجربه الاولى في الاخبار لاستخدام
الواقع الممتد في الاخبار حنين يعني في
العشر سنوات في عملنا في العربيه كنا لما
نحب نشرح والله نحط الانتخابات الكويت
الكويتيه مثلا وخارطه
من واقع تجربه يعني كان يقعد الجرافيكس
يشتغل لمده يوم او يومين او ثلاثه في
العشر سنوات الثانيه فرحنا حينما كانت
الدبابه تتحرك اليوم تقنيات كثيره عندك
وهائله وحتى تتحركين بل تصعدين الى يعني
سفينه وتصعدين الى الفضاء
كيف تتعاملين مع كل هذا الامر خلينا
ناخذها من جانب
يعني حطيت ايدك على اهم نقطه هي من خلال
هذه التقنيه
محاكاه عادل لا يحتمل
مجاملات على الهواء
بالضبط تحدث في اختصاص في صميم اختصاص هذا
البرنامج يعني البرنامج صحيح هي التجربه
المثلى
الواقع المعزز في الانتخابات ظهرت في
العربيه في عام 2016 اخذت جائزه افضل قناه
تغطي الانتخابات الامريكيه على سبيل
المثال في البرنامج الساعه ستون احنا نعمل
محاكاه حرب انتما غطيتما الحرب على الارض
عادل
رجعت منك قبل يومين
على الارض التجربه طبعا جدا قويه ولكن
مختلفه بالطبع والصوره الحيه جدا مهمه
ولكن لما يكون عندك قدره انك انت تجمع
عوامل في عرض واحد مثل انه احنا نحاكي
الحرب مثلا دبابه الليو بارد كيف تتصرف
امام الدبابه الروسيه لما تقدر من خلال
محاكاه انك انت تصعد للفضاء كما قلتي ليال
وبنفس الوقت انك انت تفوت داخل مجرى الدم
مشان ترصد كيف بتفاعل
هو نقل الخبر بطريقه بصريه يعني تشد
المشاهد وايضا تعطي الخبر حقه حنين ساعود
اليك للحديث عن نقطه اخرى غير الستوري
موضوع ريدي فاين نيوز او اعاده تعريف
الخبر وكل ما الى هناك ولكن اسمحي لي ان
اعود الى الزميل بيرغانم واشنطن وعادل معك
بما انك يعني
عملتم سويه كل هذه العشرين عام ابرز
اللحظات الشخصيه التي ممكن ان تتحدث عنها
تفضل انا انا خليني اقول لك وردتني رساله
حينما كنت في اوكرانيا
ما راح اقول شنو كانت الرساله هذه اعتبرها
من شخص ومن زميل يعني كانت وسام على صدري
وكانت دفعه الى الامام باني لا اخشى شيء
بل امضي الى الامام في هذه التغطيه في
اوكرانيا قبل اشهر
يلا اتفضل
ان تتحدث عن
ابشع اللحظات واحلى اللحظات بهذه التجربه
تجربه 20 عام بما ان التجربه الشخصيه
دائما هي جزء كبير من التجربه المهنيه
اسمحي لي اني كمان مره وجه تحيه لاي شخص
ترك المبنى وراح الى ساحه المعركه هيدا
عمل بيتطلب من كل انسان انه يتخطى نفسه
ويتطلب من كل انسان انه يملك الشجاعه حتى
يقول للمشاهد انه انا موجود بساحه الخطر
من شان من شان المشاهد وانا بعثت له لعادل
رساله وقلت له فيها انه انا بحترمك كتير
وبقدر كتير انك انت طلعت من المبنى ورحت
على هذه التغطيه وهذه طبعا شي
بينطبق على كثير من الزملاء يلي تركوا
المبنى بدبي او باي مكان اخر تركوا حياتهم
العاديه الى مكان في خطر وهذا الشيء انا
هالمقليله انا ما عملته تحيه مره لالكم
بالنسبه لالي انا بعتقد انه في لحظتين او
ثلاثه مرقوا بحياه المهنيه مع العربيه على
طول بتذكرهم
الخوف
من عامين بوسط الجائحه
طلبت مني غرفه الاخبار اني اروح على مدينه
نيويورك مدينه فيها عشر ملايين انسان تدخل
عليها مئات الاف السيارات باليوم وبتخرج
منها ملايين الناس بدخلوا كل يوم وبيطلعوا
منها كنت اوقف بوسط الطريق وما في انسان
ما في سياره ما في شيء مدينه متروكه
وفاضيه وكانت هيدي لحظه الرعب الكبيره
بالنسبه لالي خلال فتره التغطيه لحظه
الثانيه اللي كان فيها كثير من الخوف هو
انه يوم المساء كان في هجوم كثير كبير من
قبل متظاهرين على ساحه قدام البيت الابيض
وانا نزلت مع المصور وبلشنا نحن ننقل
الوقت يلي كانوا عم يهجموا فيها
المتظاهرين على الساحه ياللي حول البيت
الابيض وكذا هذا خلال التظاهرات يلي بترفض
مقتل جورج فلويد وبعدين اج
[ضحك]
حركه مسرح وماريوبولي يعكس
يتظاهر الالاف من الفرنسيين اليوم في
العاصمه باريس
[موسيقى]
يتظاهر
نحن الان امام مخرجي مصنع
[تصفيق]
نحن الان في اقليمي
الاستاذ عادل امام الفنان الكبير وحضرتك
ادليه بصوتك قلقان ازي حضرتك
انت فخر البنت المصريه
في ميدان التحرير ومزنوقه زنقه والناس
ملمومه عليك والدنيا حر وحاجه ملزقه ومش
ممكن نتحدث عن حياتك اليوم ادلب بصوتك في
حاجه تانيه افضل قبل سيطره القوات الروسيه
وبلغه عده من قريه قريه
السلام عليكم
خاصه
خربطت كل شيء تغير بالكامل الاعلام التي
ترفرف والوجود العسكري المكثف
[موسيقى]
خطير جدا ان تتعامل مع هذه الحيوانات
المفترسه فسياسه التعامل معها تحتاج الى
خبره سنوات لتتمكن من
ثانكيو
بالعربيه التلفزيون
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هيكشي
غلط اوكي لشو خلص فهمنا
شو بده هذا الاراضي الاوكرانيه
نقول هذا طيب عمليه تبريدها تحتاج لكميات
هائله من المياه وهذا ما دفع
معنا مشاهدينا من باريس مراسل العربيه ليس
بازاري ليس يعني شاهدت معنا التقرير انا
شهدت على كثير من الاحداث والحوادث التي
حصلت معك على الهواء مباشره لتغطيه قبل
شويه
بكل التغطيات التي حصلت حتى بالحرب
وبالماسات يعني كان هناك مقابل الدراما
كان هناك يعني حوادث مضحكه على الهواء كيف
يمكن ان تضبط اعصابك على الهواء بذل كل ما
يحدث
اول شيء بدي اقول كل عام ونحن في العربيه
وانتم امام شاشتنا بالف خير واقول لكل
متابع للعربيه عبر التلفاز او منصات شبكه
العربيه المختلفه شكرا للثقه بنا وهنا
اريد ان اسلط الضوء على موضوع المنصات
منصات شبكتنا خصوصا في التخطيات يا ليال
عادل فهناك اخبار تكون عاده يا مناسبه
للشاشه او للمنصات او للويب سات موقع
العربيه فهاي بتصير يعني هذا اهم شيء انا
كنت بدي احكي عنه لانه الواحد بيتميز بهيك
قصص بتكون لما منحكي عن موضوع يخاطب خليني
اقول جيل معين لانه مش كل واحد بيحضر
السوشيال ميديا انستجرام او تيك توك او او
اشياء تانيه بكون من نفس الجير الذي يشاهد
التلفاز وهذا مهم جدا ودائما بالتخطيات
بتصير معنا اشياء كثيره
والاشياء يعني مش الطريقه اللي شفناها قبل
شوي ولكن الاشياء اللي دائما نبحث عن
التميز قبل شوي سمعت انه بحكي على
اوكوهاما وقت جائحه كورونا دائما
البرانسيس فاللي كان مهم بالموضوع انا
دائما
انت ليش عصبي ليش عصبي
يعني
ما مشيت معك عصبي
لانه اللي بصير عادل عاده الواحد يعني
بكون بحاول اكتر من مره بده ياخذ اللقطه
بالمكان المناسب وبالوقت المناسب بيجي مثل
ما شفنا قبل شوي بالكواليس بيجي واحد يا
بيقطع قدامك الواحد بعصب للحظات ولكن
الهدوء بعد العاصفه دائما على كل حال
التميز انه يكون الواحد الواحد مساء الخير
نحكي بس قصه
خصوصا هاي القصه لانه سمعت الصوت قبل شوي
عن نيوكهاما انا اتعود من الشيطان من
الشيطان لما بشوف وكالات الانباء
والتلفزيونات بقول هاي الصوره موجوده
عندكم بدبي دائما نبحث عن التميز ويوم هاي
الباخره قررنا ناخذ قارب سريع ونروح من
جهه بحر اليابان لنوصل للكانه محجورين في
الباخره ونحكي معهم وقصص كثيره يعني اذا
حكينا كمان عن
الحدود
الاوكرانيه دول الجوار ان كان بالرومانيا
او بولندا الكل كان يحكي عن اللاجئين
وخروج
الاوكرانيين الى بولندا او رومانيا انا
دائما حاولت يعني سلطنا الضوء حتى بتقارير
لايفات او مباشره عن موضوع الشباب
الاوكراني الذي كان يترك اوكرانيا خوفا من
التجديد العسكري او الاجباري فكان برضه
هذا تقريبا احد التقارير واللايفات اللي
عملناها على الحدود الرومانيه الاوكرانيه
طبعا مع الجيش الروماني لنرصد كيف هالشباب
بتركوا البلد بتركوا اوكرانيا بطرق غير
شرعيه للهروب وفي قصص كثيره طبعا اذا
حكينا
بالنسبه لنا وما لا يعرفه المشاهد ان ليس
بازاري ما يميزه ان ثقافته التي يستطيع من
خلالها تغطيه اي حدث فاشن رياضه اخبار
لاجئين سياحه
يعني هذا شيء لا لا يملكه الكثيرين من
المراسلين والمذيعين على الهواء لذلك تحيه
لك ليث بالعيد العشرين العربيه على كل ما
تقوم بهذه المؤسسه اسمح لي ليس ان اعود
الى الزميله حنين
الشولين كنا نسال عن النقطه بموضوع يعني
التحديث الذي ادخلتموه على برنامج او على
الخبر تحديدا هو
ما معنى ذلك
يعني تحدثنا قبل قليل عن التقنيه ولكن اود
ان اشرح قليلا عن طريقه العمل للبرنامج
نحن فريق صحفي كبير يعمل من بدايه الاسبوع
على تحديد المواضيع سويا نعمل ايضا مع قسم
الابداع من بدايه الاسبوع نحن لدينا
حلقتين في نهايه الاسبوع وبالتالي ننسق كل
هذا العمل منذ بدايه الاسبوع اي اننا نبدا
من المراحل الاولى بهذه الشراكه مع قسم
الابداع طبعا وايضا الشركاء مع الاخراج
وهذا يعني ان البرنامج هو قائم على ثلاثه
عناصر الصحفي
والمخرج والفريق التقني طبعا وايضا
المبدعين الذين يعملون على تصوير هذه
المعلومات بكل هذه التقنيات همم لتخرج على
طريقه قصه للمشاهد تشرح له تفاصيل وابعاد
وعمق الخبر الذي نتعاطى معه
يعني حنين خليني انا من خلال هذه يعني
الدقيقه اوجه الشكر الى زملائنا وبالتالي
القسم الجرافيكس لاني اعلم كيفيه عملهم
وبالتالي كم يجلسون على هذه القصه حتى
تخرج بالصوره
بالضبط ايضا اسم الابداع
وما يصلون اليه حتى المخرجين المخرج اللي
يخلي هذا المذيع يتحرك بخطوه الى الامام
وخطوه الى الوراء كيفيه جماليه الصوره
وبالتالي يقدمها الى المشاهد عبر الشاشه
وكذلك ايضا المنفذين وكل الزملاء طاقم
اللي داخل الغرفه الاخبار وخارجها ايضا
تجسدت هذه الشراكه يعني بالقدر يعني
متساوي بين العناصر الثلاثه بين الصحافه
وقسم التحرير بين الابداع وايضا مع
الاخراج
كلهم حقيقه يعني ما هو موجود في الساعه
ستون هو موجود ايضا في نشرات الاخبار
موجوده ايضا في البرامج شكرا جزيلا للكل
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا جزيلا لليث بازاري
كذلك في ارغانم شكرا جزيلا لي قبل لا
اشكرك
شكرا للزملاء يعني ينعاد عليكم وعلى
العربيه مجددا ولكن قبل ان اختم هذه
الساعه ساسال عادل عن تجربته في العربيه
بعدما رافق العربيه لعقدين من الزمن عادل
انت من المؤسسين يعني حتى ولم يعجبك
السؤال بما انه عقدين يعني زمن طويل ما
الذي يمكن ان
اقول لك بكل امانه
لحظات فرح لحظات بكاء لحظات
الم كل كل ما تتصورين مشاعر عشتها في هذه
السنوات لربما الان وانا في موقف انه بنتي
تتعالج في الخارج لم اجد الا كل كل محبه
من كل الزملاء من الاداره ومن كل الصحفيين
حقيقه
رحم الله نجوى يعني
اطوار بهجت الزملائنا اللي كنا نخاف عليهم
في جبهات القتال زملائنا اللي كنا نتمنى
نراهم دائما من كان معنا ومن غادر
الى كلمه او بكلمتين ماذا تقول عائلتي
عائلتي
كل من التقيت فيهم داخل المؤسسه
وخارج ههه
دائما يعني عندما تدخل الى الاستوديو ارى
الفرحه والبسمه على وجوه الجميع مع انك
يعني اوقات بتثقل دم ما عندي مشكله
الميزه فيها غرفه الاخبار انه يتحملوني
وبالتالي هم عارفين من هو عادل من القلب
الى القلب ليس هناك رسول تصل دائما شكرا
جزيلا شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على وفائكم وعلى
يعني متابعتكم دائما لشاشات العربيه
وللعربيه ولكل فريق كل عام وانتم بالف خير
قناه العربيه بمناسبه مرور 20 عاما على
انشائها حققت الهدف المطلوب منها تماما
وهو بوضوح شديد للغايه الدفاع عن المصالح
العربيه
واطلاع المواطن العربي في كل مكان على
حقائق الامور
كان العرب يحتاجون لمثل هذه القناه لكم كل
التوفيق والنجاح في مستقبل الايام
[موسيقى]